again to for honor which judging by
traffic for for honor stories on
gamespot for the past two years gamespot
audience really liked for honor at least
is excited about it or cares a lot about
it we've been playing it Rob and I like
I said Cal he's been busy with Halo Wars
to have you played a 400 all I have not
and my first question for you is I don't
care about it at all I have not been
interested in a question should not
there yet should I be shut up my [ __ ]
sorry should I be um should I be more
interested than I am like should I have
this on my radar from what you've played
I'm more interested than I initially was
I've had answered your question um yeah
you were kind of every time I would
mention it even did you play Barry bug
no I'm uninterested literally I've heard
a coming up well I played that closed
alpha back in the day okay um and it did
interest me but I think now that I think
we kind of want to focus a little more
in the story mode during the segment but
obviously we talk about the whole game I
think just cuz story modes the new thing
no one's touched yet well game released
yesterday so I guess people have touched
it now but it was one of those games
where it was much deeper than I
initially thought like really deep in
the sense that there are a lot of things
that tutorials won't even tell you where
the game might not tell you initially
that you know its emergence stuff that
comes up as you play more um if you're
looking for just a good story Timon I
don't don't I is it is it really bad
because I wouldn't I wouldn't expect a
great story a game that's multiplayer
focused its service bleich yeah for the
story mode purposes so the story mode
functions just kind of like a training
gown for a moat really is yeah and it
will show you different you know you can
follow the path of this warden for the
Knights um then follow the path of a
samurai with the samurai and then a
Viking and it becomes this each you got
to you learn new moves in each mission
and then it also frames it with this
bare-bones story which rob you have you
can't really stand can you yeah it was
kind I'm I just wasn't into it yeah well
it's not trying to like Doc the game for
not having a good story because I didn't
expect at all and it's a
multiplayer-focused game so yeah but I
don't but it see it's almost to the
point where it's like painfully cheesy
at some parts yeah that's the difference
is it's like I
it doesn't have to have a good story but
if the story is so painful that I don't
want to get through it that's another
story that will fall it's not another
story you know what I need that bad but
it is it's our time experiment Riven
boring it for myself here this scene
right here he says uh he was expecting
an army they sent me oh my god yeah no
that's the man doing man things just got
yeah dudes I'm just a couple of guys be
good for me what actually kind of just
like pics it sounds like minor but what
kind of takes me out of it is the fact
that only once so far I've played like
the first three four chapters of the
crusade whether this is a warden excuse
me warden yeah you don't see anyone's
face you see won't you see the main 11
days and it's just it just comes off as
just a guy in a vo booth that's what I
keep hearing maybe that's because like I
really enjoyed voice acting from the
most part i'd like to hear good voice
acting and so it's just two guys in
helmets I just feel like I'm not I just
feel I'm looking at talking helmet sure
and that gets tiring for me where I keep
seeing two guys who aren't looking at
each other you're just looking away for
it's just like a it nags me I'll dudes
who can't look each other in the eye
well like you said the big problem is
not with not seeing face she's not
having some kind of facial emo they do
these emphatic dumb gestures right time
because how else are you going to you
know visualize someone talking or
someone expressing concern or emotions
so you have these exaggerated our
motions like I'm going over here yeah
it's very ruined but I'm waving my arms
around choice can we cut back to rob's
we can do it one more time sorry come on
let's go or it's like I'm right here it
just gets annoying yeah for me and I get
tired of that yeah and like we said I
don't think any of us were expecting
great story but in terms of the
structure of the campaign how it
functions within the game to prep you
from multiplayer I think it
serviceable it gets repetitive when
you're just plowing through the I don't
know if you want to call Mike creeps I
guess if you're going to use a mobile
term plumbing through them but then
obviously the game has best when you're
fighting another hero unit once you have
to block and Perry and use specific
attacks against and that's where the
multiplayer comes in because those
characters are other players and it does
a good job prepping you I would actually
recommend if you're playing for the
first time campaign serves the story
mode I don't even know if they call it a
campaign but you get what I'm saying it
does a good job of showing you the ropes
for sure rather than just a barebone
tutorial and there's like high
production value this game looks really
good yes he does and it's cool like
going through I guess again it's not a
river ice it's not a riveting story it's
just again it facilitates everything so
the campaign i would recommend jumping
into it first but i want to talk about
the multiplayer this game is far deeper
than I I think we all were thinking it
would be but it's definitely far deeper
than we all initially thought or a lot
of us it's it's like a 3d fighting game
mixed with these mobile aspects which I
think are implemented really well it can
be intimidating to go up against people
because you have three block directions
you have these three attack directions
but you also have a heavy attack a light
attack you have these shield bashes like
body slams you have these drop attacks
it's it's crazy like they actually
managed to make this multiplayer mail a
game with kind of modern multiplayer
tenants like control zones and whatnot
and as MOBA creeps and it works well I
like it how's the balancing for you so
far um in terms of like the character
balance yeah it I think it is best in
the sense that you know you're going up
against chef Rick up with this Viking
he's fighting right now is called so I
believe this is a warden that they're
playing as the Knights warden but you
have to read each character differently
and there are Telegraph's to certain
moves each each fight against another
player feels like a boss fight almost
this duel because you can dodge but you
can also block but you have to block in
the right direction so this I don't know
there's like a Valkyrie character and
they might be the ones with a spear
they'll be harder to read but they're
faster and do less damage but they'll be
harder to read than a warden might with
this two-handed sword oh this isn't a
warden is a samurai sorry but you can
see which side are holding the store
down so you see where they're going to
from you can kind of Perry it but yeah
it feels really balanced in terms of how
you know this one character is really
fast and quick and dodge based more of a
you know kind of like a rogue skirmisher
or something as opposed to this tank
character who deals a lot of damage
there's a Valkyrie right there if I'm
not mistaken it it feels balanced and it
feels like each character has their own
very distinct style and it feels like
every time I go up against one I'm
learning something new every time I'm
nowhere near being a good player right
destroy me it's I have like a conflict
as I've been playing the campaign or the
story mode it's you know you you know
you lock on to a guy you do thats like
just like square off and a couple times
i thought i was actually i don't know i
thought i was in the right mode but it
was actually just a I've yeah they put
like a clan tag on it I'm arresting like
I know this isn't a real person but man
that'd be intense yes she just had these
situations i was watching Matt play for
like two minutes and he was playing
online and the teamwork seems real heavy
and that's what's like cool is you know
you really want to like have some team
Jack going because he was doing like he
was up against this one guy another dude
comes in so now it's 2 v1 and those
situations you're just you're really on
a retreat you're just all defense so he
just learned these guys into a hallway
and then came out and his buddy was
there one of the other enemies was like
almost done he was clearly trying to get
to him but he was the guy was behind his
alone lure him out and his teammate just
came with a finisher yeah there are a
lot of great moments in this oh it was
just mad played it so right it was just
like I that was two minutes of just
watching the moves it looked really
really intense we have people in this
office that play like street fighter or
marvel vs capcom all the time and you
went you obviously it's a fighting game
you can watch and notice when someone's
good as opposed to just button mashing
and this is very much a fighting game if
two people go up against each other
brand new they'll probably button mash
and I think Spencer who's been playing
this a lot in our office says it's one
of those games where you have to really
be patient despite how frenetic it looks
and you have to take the time defense is
huge in this game which I love it's not
it looks like dynasty Warriors when you
going up against creeps but when you
again when you go up against a hero
right here there's out of nowhere I
love the feeling of being like plowing
through creeps and trying to push that
front and then all of a sudden here
comes on where the [ __ ] right holy like
a whole different game it's becoming
more about wits it's funny when you see
two people that know what they're doing
going up against each other because
they'll be switching their guards
waiting for the other to attack right so
it's like it's like it reminds me the
scene in the office where Dwight and
Michael and Andy at the end of the
role-playing game Savannah murder
they're just like it's like a standoff
and you're looking at each other I don't
know if it's got nothing to do proposes
and it's like an interpretive dance
against each other uh it would like the
dude into NYADA Jones and rangers lost
ark who's fleeing his sword around and
he just take house gun and shoots him I
wish you ready that in this game well I
mean I'm seeing some like arrows with
like the samurai right those like kind
of like cool down like abilities you
have not yet yeah pick up abilities you
rank up in campaign they're separate
than multiplayer but yeah you get these
you can get these flags you plant that
heel people around you or increase
attack you can get these passive
abilities map to directional sorry if
their passive you don't need to map them
but you these passive abilities they
just increase your damage I've it why
not that you can map to a directional
pad that just refills your health
briefly and yeah there's it's a it is a
deep game I I want to play more of it
and it is tough to get into it's a high
learning curve for sure but that was a
question yes yeah very very high
especially now would be the time to get
in i guess but but don't every magical
learning right but then matchmaking
comes into play right hopefully it I
don't know our reviews not up yet I have
to like ask Madison oh he's reviewing it
what he thinks of the matchmaking and
how they pair you up against other
players of similar experience yeah cuz
my problem is always like join in with
friends who are who have been playing
longer than I have then I get into these
matches I'm not prepared for it happened
to me an overwatch a ton yeah it's it's
an intimidating game for sure but it's
the fact that like Ubisoft releases and
Ubisoft has aside from like the division
hasn't had a ton of new ip's i think
this is like a lot more military focused
or you know shooters like far cry this
is a great entry so far from what I've
played I didn't really been enjoying it
it's to be honest it's not something I'm
gonna stick with right now because of so
many other games come out coming out but
it is pretty creative in some great ways
and
obviously this footage is kind of
showing it off but you have these
control points these capture points
there's always something going through
your head like that's cool it's it's one
of those things where you see that
there's a hero unit down there
destroying your creeps you're like [ __ ]
should I go try to push that front or
flank around behind em and get this
control point to let us work spawn in
back here it is a much more intelligent
game than it's you know bro
testosterone-fueled story mode my imply
and also just had like the mem marketing
might imply it's a very intelligent game
actually and I really like how the
system's play together and I'm looking
forward to trying to learn a character
that's like that's like the you know the
hero aspect of it right trying to learn
this Viking and then trying to learn
this samurai and figuring out how this
night works I'm looking forward to that
aspect if I get to play more but yeah I
guess my recommendation jump into the
story mode first and that'll definitely
show you the ropes or if you just want
trial by fire jump into multiplayer you
might be way better than I was just yeah
I definitely want to get through the
single-player just to get like a better
understanding of like three different
classes right like that's what I'm like
more different factions factions sir I
forget how me and then there are files
there like I think they're like oh three
or four classes with infections correct
yes Oh yep so they'll have like a night
the warden is two-handed sword but then
they'll also have one that's faster and
speedier there are certain heroes that
are female specific certain that our
mouths specific and there's some that
you can customize either way okay um I
know like the Valkyrie Viking the spear
is always female and she's one of my
favorite ones oh I love Vikings yes it
is oh yeah so clear Kaleo Walker a while
back in the YouTube chat i wrote this
down he was asking what our favorite
faction is uh Callie what would would it
be Vikings a few had played I mean I
just love Vikings in general because
it's my actual heritage okay Celtic yeah
same here you're Rob what do you I got
some Irish for me okay cool alright well
cherish FIFA I like the samurai in this
game they're my their my faction of
choice or not the one I'm trying to
learn well I'm also a weeaboos so
probably would like the same right so
just kill all the nights you see it
sounds like you you know your allegiance
yeah you sound really piss
I don't lend a nice take it out in the
field I'll settle this in the castle
what faction you been playing I actually
picked samurai um but yeah again like I
don't know I picked it to play a little
multiplayer and I was like no I all have
been playing has the N you know the
Vanguard yeah Crusaders is there some
sort of uh what's the term asynchronous
multiplayer in this game we're like
there's this constant war between the
three factions I saw one ever said is
that exactly cool it kind of looked like
that I want to master the allegiances
between different factions right I would
be a shame not to do that but it looked
like that same map and I wishing knew
for sure look like that same map also
was broken out into like game modes
right as well yeah yeah there's Dominion
there's a the game modes are skating me
right now but there are some that are
more a control base there are some that
are you know just the one we 1v1 hero
mode actually once you jump in a
multiplayer after you play story mode do
1v1 hero mode first to figure out how
sorry someone just mentioned Syracuse in
the chat apex penguin Mike sir explain
or I keep going I know if he's in
Syracuse but it's weird my hometown ah
keep going I'm sorry around me 1v1 got
some memories came flooding back
Syracuse that's a name I haven't heard a
long time um 1v1 is a good way to get
introduced a multiplayer so then when
you see a hero on the battlefield you're
not like how the [ __ ] do I fight them
you're like okay I did this against this
one guy in that mode now maybe I could
do it while there are creeps all around
me and then potentially wanted to more
people coming in because when you start
fighting 1v2 it's so [ __ ] bad ass to
see someone who knows what they're doing
like if me and my friend are hacking at
this dude and he's blocking both or
attacks we could do it yeah John wick if
he was a samurai right or Keanu Reeves a
few of the samurai which is just the
plot of 47 Ronin or Tom Cruise if he was
or Tom Cruise if he was the last samurai
or seven dudes who were Sam Ryan is
seven samurai yeah now I get it um do
you see John with two yet no I want to
duh I really want to learn how to fight
off two people at once and then three
and then like and then like and then an
army yeah all right and I'm saying I'm
so I want to be able to dodge bullets I
want to be able to do that move I see in
this game where you like knock someone's
for an execution he knocks Mosley
down and then you just do the classic
cutting off of the head yeah there's
this one that makes sense to me the
wardens so if you've come one with a
heavy attack okay you have the choice to
do an execution square or triangle so if
you press square it does it's cool on
we're like it she the warden will just
turn around and like go up through
middle of the body right the heavy one
they'll grab the sword by the blade let
ab the hilt into the shoulder in there
and pull it which doesn't make sense to
me you have a weapon you could puncture
may be right but we also have a weapon
that has a blade on it and you're
choosing your you're like holding the
spoon by the stroller and trying to eat
with this see Mike it's more badass if
you could cut your hands when attacking
it's like a blood oath yes sounding a
lot like the kylo Ren saber yeah we'll
have some guy will have to make a video
of like here's a hilt with blades yes we
need to see that well yeah it doesn't
make sense to me I wardens aren't as
well trained as they talk about mmm but
anyway for Honor's fun it's tough be
ready to devote some time to it if you
really want to learn it but I recommend
it mattis pinellas review will be up
sometime soon as she's plowing through
like a lot of it seems like he's pretty
high ranked by this point it seems like
a pretty good I don't want to play him
because I'll get my ass kicked but yeah
forerunner that is out now and ps4 xbox
one pc to go check that out let us know
you think once you play it if you have
played it let us know you think kelly
plaguey on twitter Rob handlery Mike
McCarty
[Music]
you